I might potentially a permanent scar for
the rest of our life worth it
that's them behind the scenes you got
your fishing stuff yeah hopefully we've
had some luck today we'll be going out
to the hailstones white fishnet which is
not too far from here it's a couple
miles down on the river the river just
froze up so there is still pretty thin
it's pretty much the thing I hate the
most
[Music]
[Music]
crazy I just fell in a hole that they
cut the ice like two days ago
just getting the shot from in front of
the hall to just chip sticking the ice
out of the hall and then I just fell in
a snow-covered hole over here which
looks exactly the same as everything
else out so straighten bail up to my
waist into the river big enough for me
to get in yeah sorry I go I got super
lucky all right so um an effort to make
really cool TV you need to have really
cool socks
we're here to channel our today Glenn's
out cutting some firewood and he's using
a sled to pull the firewood through the
forest back to his cabin we're gonna set
up a GoPro on a pulley system here so
that we can catch Glen as he's walking
up this hill we're gonna have a GoPro
going down the hill sliding right at him
should be a great action shot
there you go get it go in
he's just trout right here and this
little hell it's proving to be a bit of
a problem for it so finally had the time
to test
go for a flying fox take one cue mark
and roll
[Music]
we need to redo it because it's wobbling
a tasty this doesn't work I'll just have
to do it myself and hold the camera
go to wait on it thank you Mark
[Music]
definitely got better but it's not
perfect we can't seem to get rid of the
wobble so unfortunately that's that's
where things go you give it a go you get
these ideas you give it a try and it
doesn't work sometimes but you'll head a
for effort
d for shots
[Music]